[Musique]
les copies de bac ont une notation qui
est justifiée en haut de la copie avec
le détail du barème pour que les élèves
comprennent sa note si l'élève souhaite
voir sa copie ensuite parce qu'il est
possible et ça les candidats -le ignore
trop souvent de consulter sa copie
l'année suivante enfin à partir de
septembre les élèves peuvent consulter
leur copie et il suffit de le demander
au centre d'examen qui stocke les
copines
[Musique]
quand on corrige la copie on est quand
même seul face à la copie mais il y a
des moments avant la correction des
moments après la correction où on se
réunit où on confronte nos idées après
la correction
nous nous réunissons encore et il y à
une commission d'harmonisation et post
correction ou là on reprend les moyennes
de correction de chaque correcteurs du
bac et on voit ben finalement est-ce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'écart comment ces
écarts peuvent s'expliquer si on voit
qu'un correcteur à des points vraiment
au moins par rapport à une moyenne
générale
on va reconsidérer son paquet peut-être
qu'il ya une raison
un objective à cette moyenne basse dans
ces cas là il n'y a pas de problème si
on considère cependant que cette moyenne
basse elle a été elle et elle était due
à une façon de corriger un peu sèche
on va revoir les notes pour les adapter
mais généralement c'est quand même assez
rare parce que on arrive à s'entendre
pour sur un secteur arriver à une
notation assez harmonieuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les copies sont anonymes et donc on ne
s'est pas qu'elle élève on corrige la
simplement les numéros d
des candidats mais aucun nom nous savons
à quel lycée appartient le candidat on
me nous ignorons tout de son identité si
vous avez un petit message crypté dans
la marge c'est totalement interdit de
laisser un message dans la marge d'une
copie parce que c'est considéré comme un
signe potentiel de reconnaissance et
c'est quelque chose qu'on doit faire
remonter aux inspecteurs et qui peut
vraiment annuler l'épreuve pour le
candidat c'est quand même très embêtant
donc il faut absolument éviter les
petites fleurs les petits les petites
étoiles tous ces petits signes qui
pourraient être considérés justement
comme un signe de reconnaissance pour un
éventuel correcteurs qu'on connaîtrait
mais comme nous ne corrigeons pas du
tout sur le lieu sur notre lieu
d'exercice
nous sommes un peu ventilée dans la
région on peut même aller assez loin
parfois
et donc nous n'avons pas en face de nous
une des élèves qu'on connaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cliché qui a la vie dure mais en fait
nos consignes c'est vraiment d'utiliser
toute l'échelle des notes donc on va
jusqu'à 20 20 c'est pas forcément la
copie idéal est parfaite c'est le
candidat qui aura fait quelque chose
justement qui va nous étonner et qui est
brillant mais du point de vue de l'élève
parce que même les professeurs s'ils
devaient faire en quatre heures le sujet
imposé il n'arriverait sûrement pas non
plus à cette copier absolument parfaite
elle n'existe pas certes mais c'est pas
une raison pour ne pas mettre vingt à
nos élèves et les ors alors des 0 ils
n'arrivent qu'en cas de copie blanche
[Musique]
c'était mieux avant alors moi je ne
pense pas pourquoi je ne le pense pas
parce que je me souviens très bien que
quand j'étais élève mes propres
professeurs n'arrêtait pas de dire
c'était mieux avant et donc je pense que
ça c'est une sensation qui est lié
beaucoup à la nostalgie personnel qu'on
a de sa propre jeunesse et finalement il
y à des élèves en difficulté il ya des
élèves brillants à toutes les époques
il peut y avoir
en effet au niveau de la maîtrise de
l'orthographe
d
une dégradation tout de même mère pour
d'autres compétences
les élèves d'aujourd'hui vont plutôt
être plus efficace quand on compare par
exemple le programme de français de 1991
par exemple à celui de maintenant les
descriptifs de baccalauréat comportait
de livres seulement à lire à cette
époque là une pièce de théâtre est un
roman est bien de nos jours les élèves
lisent huit livres voit tellement de
jolies choses dans les copies que c'est
dommage de laisser sur les réseaux
sociaux s'étendre ces remarques qui en
plus souvent sont elles mêmes plein de
fautes